Here's everything my toddlers eat in a day.
They eat whatever lucky and I are eating that day.
I don't cook them any extra meals.
And also, every day looks different.
But today we started off our day by making some
blueberry coconut granola
to go on top of some Greek yogurt.
So once the granola was all cooled down,
I assembled their little yogurt bowls with Greek yogurt,
banana, raspberry,
and a drizzle of honey.
They ended up snacking on the granola all morning long,
so that was their mid morning snack.
Then right before lunch,
I pulled out my focaccia dough
that had been resting in the fridge overnight
just to let it rise at room temperature.
My beverage of choice today was an asteroid with tea
while I got started on some lunch.
We have a lot of ground meat in the fridge,
so I decided to make some wontons today.
The filling was just pork, cilantro,
spring onions,
and then obviously
the usual seasoning.
I don't know what it was,
but my wrappers kept breaking,
so I decided to just leave my wontons as triangles
instead of forming them properly.
As a side, I made some sauteed broccolini
and bok choy with some garlic.
Once the wontons were done,
I tossed them in my sesame soy dipping sauce
and plated it all up.
Their afternoon snack,
they had some Parmesan cheese,
olives, and some apples.
The apples need to be sliced this way, though,
or else They won't have it.
I don't know why.
At this point,
my focaccia was ready to get dimpled,
so I did that
and topped it with some red onions,
olives, and some cherry tomatoes.
Pop that in the oven
while I got started on some lamb meatballs.
These were just ground lamb,
Greek yogurt,
some egg yolk,
bread crumbs,
seasoning, and then I rolled them up on a baking tray.
Put those in the oven to broil.
Once they were done,
I started on my sundried tomato sauce.
So I sauteed my onion,
my tomato paste,
sundried tomato paste,
added some fresh tomatoes,
and my lamb meatballs
back into that.
Focaccia was done baking.
I sliced it up,
and then it was time to plate.
So I plated the meatballs with the focaccia
and obviously had to add Parmesan cheese on top.